alguna vez te has dado cuenta que en tu
núcleo más profundo y más interno en
realidad no eres tú
bueno piénsalo en el momento en que
comes algo lo tragas y pasa a través de
tu tracto gastrointestinal es el
ambiente externo esa comida que acabas
de tomar en la parte del mundo exterior
y el tracto que va a seguir desde tu
boca hasta el punto en que lo expulsase
en el baño en realidad no eres tú es el
ambiente externo que tan raro es eso en
este vídeo vamos a tener una visión
general del tracto gastrointestinal
hablaré de cada una de las partes
individuales y cuáles son las funciones
principales y luego en vídeos
subsiguientes voy a revisar cada una de
esas partes individuales y dar una
explicación más detallada de cómo hacen
lo que hacen muy bien así que para
comenzar por supuesto el primer lugar
por donde entra la comida es nuestra
boca o la cavidad oral las principales
funciones que llevamos a cabo en la boca
incluyen la masticación la trituración
de los alimentos también es muy
importante la hidrólisis como recordarás
el avión
y la hidrólisis es solo la digestión
enzimática o la descomposición
enzimática masticar es la descomposición
física y la hidrólisis es la
descomposición de los alimentos asistida
por enzimas entonces mientras
descomponemos el alimento el objetivo es
hacer lo que se llama un bolo solo una
esfera de comida digerida que luego se
puede deglutir o tragar y pasar a
nuestra siguiente estructura de modo que
después de tragar la comida adónde crees
que va
a este amigo que es el esófago el
esófago está creo que es una de las
partes más aburridas del tracto
gastrointestinal porque lo único que
hacemos aquí es impulsar nuestro bolo
simplemente se lo pasamos al siguiente
amigo ni siquiera le hacemos nada un
poco aburrido pero el siguiente chico es
un poco más emocionante ahora llegamos
al estómago hay mucha acción en el
estómago una de mis partes favoritas del
tracto gastrointestinal el estómago es
responsable de múltiples cosas
incluyendo la mezcla que es muy parecida
a masticar excepto que hay más
dimensiones de contracción que afectan
del alimento y lo descomponen también
tenemos hidrólisis aquí la
descomposición de los alimentos asistida
por enzimas además de eso podemos
almacenar alimentos en el estómago si no
es hora de transmitir los al siguiente
componente del tracto gastrointestinal
el objetivo general aquí es hacer lo que
se llama quimo de modo que tomamos
nuestro bolo y lo licuamos en este tipo
de sustancia más fluida que podemos
transmitir a nuestros
destinos así que ahora nos estamos
moviendo a nuestros intestinos
comenzando ahora desde este punto donde
tenemos nuestro duodeno y luego todo
circula por aquí y terminamos en este
punto todo lo de enmedio lo escribiré
aquí solo lo voy a agrupar por ahora
como el intestino delgado hay tres
partes aquí y hablaremos de eso en un
vídeo posterior pero las principales
funciones que logramos aquí son
hidrólisis y también la absorción de
nutrientes fíjense que esta es la
primera parte del tracto
gastrointestinal en la que finalmente se
toma parte de la separación de los
productos alimenticios y se usa para
nutrición para hacer otros productos en
el cuerpo excelente ahora que hemos
pasado por el intestino delgado que
creen que aparece a continuación a
partir del final del intestino delgado
todo el camino a través de esta
estructura que tenemos aquí es el
intestino grueso el intestino grueso
recuerdan el otro nombre para el
intestino grueso comienza con un hace sí
dijeron colon es absolutamente
recto el colon también es una de las
partes más aburridas del tracto
gastrointestinal porque realmente todo
lo que tenemos aquí es absorción pero no
de nutrientes sino de cosas como agua
iones o vitamina k solo se absorben
cosas así en el intestino grueso
entonces no es un lugar de alto
rendimiento para la adquisición de
nutrientes después de eso vamos a pasar
el alimento a esta estructura que se
llama el recto el recto algo así como el
estómago del tracto gastrointestinal el
recto sirve para el almacenamiento nos
aferramos a nuestra comida procesada si
todavía podemos llamarla así y se
mantiene allí hasta que consideramos un
momento apropiado para expulsarla
entonces cuando es hora de expulsar el
alimento saldrá por el ano por expulsión
estos son todos los componentes clave de
nuestro tracto gastrointestinal hay
otros órganos accesorios que están
involucrados en la digestión y tendré
vídeos que hablan de ellos también
incluyen cosas como el hígado la
vesícula biliar el páncreas y aparecerán
en vídeos post
eres